la question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre qui me répondra
peut-être puisque je l'interroge sur le
fond des choses
avec vous Madame la première ministre le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes
baisse avec vous la voiture qui était
jusqu'à présent un bien accessible et en
train de devenir un produit de luxe
pour beaucoup de familles la voiture est
indispensable cela vaut pour le monde
rural mais pas seulement prenons une
famille le papa la maman travaille ils
ont chacun besoin d'un véhicule et pour
peu qu'il y ait des jeunes adultes à la
maison qui étudient qui sont dans
l'apprentissage il leur faut aussi un
véhicule cela fait trois véhicules dans
la famille l'actuel croissance très
importante d'esprit pénalise ce type de
famille et vous êtes pour partie
responsable en ayant fait le choix de
désorganiser le marché en multipliant
les normes et les malus aujourd'hui le
prix moyen d'une voiture neuve et de 26
800 euros et vous avez également fait le
choix de désorganiser les marchés pour
longtemps en allant vers le tout
électrique à marche forcée quel que soit
les aides publiques la voiture
électrique reste et restera plus cher
que la voiture thermique c'est un saut
dans connu en termes d'emploi en termes
de souveraineté et même en matière
environnementale nous avions une valeur
industrie automobile l'Europe nous
l’enviait quand sera-t-il demain déjà la
voiture neuve et devenue hors de prix
pour nos concitoyens plus 18 % c'est 12
derniers mois voilà la réalité c'est
d'où la précipitation vers les véhicules
d'occasion aujourd'hui pour une vente de
véhicules neufs il y a 9 ventes de
véhicules d'occasion et le prix des
véhicules d'occasion monte sensiblement
alors madame la Première ministre
candonnez-vous enfin la priorité aux
familles face à la bien-pensance
écologiste comment comptez-vous
maîtriser cette hausse des prix de
l'automobile
je vous